fragt mich nicht wie ich meinen
führerschein bestanden habe ich habe
einen führerschein
und
das heißt ich kann eigentlich auto
fahren jetzt habe ich mir
eine app heruntergeladen die fahrschule
simulator heißt also die simulation
einer fahrschule
wir können uns hier ein auto auswählen
und zwar haben wir hier einen golf ich
weiß ja dass ein gti ich glaube das
sollte dem golf gti sein
die car es nicht freigeschaltet der bmw
ist freigeschaltet
der ferrari ist freigeschaltet hammer
ist auch nicht freigeschaltet er will
noch ein audi a8 dann haben wir hier
noch ein sls amg tatsächlich und dann
haben auch unser golf mit dem wir sparen
können wir können jetzt ihr auswählen
wie das ganze steuern wollen ich würde
sagen wir machen einfach mal so und
bewegen unser handy das übrigens ein
pixel 2 seht ihr oben wieder werbe video
eingeblendet weil das ganze video hier
in kooperation mit google player
entstanden ist und zwar meinen die vida
loca hat die irgendein spiel um platz
drei und endspiel ist einfach da hab ich
mir gedacht ich mache im fahrstuhl autor
niemals karte erst mal die standardkarte
also die erste jetzt steht hier laden
und das heißt es lädt das hier sind wir
wir sind ein äusserst muskulärer typ wir
können nicht rumlaufen oder irgendwas
aber hey
sie sehen schon echt geile aus keine
ahnung was das hier für eine stadt ist
ich glaube das sollte irgendwie keine
ahnung was da stellen in der großstadt
oder sowas aber wir kriegen jetzt
einfach mal hier drauf bewegen uns sind
jetzt im auto drin und jetzt können wir
den hebel nämlich von d
wtf
was ist denn mit der polizei los alter
markt passt davon
ihr habt mich gerade einfach gerannt
die polizei sollte lieber mal ein
fahrsimulator machen also es gibt hier
rechts dm neutral und reverse also wir
gehen jetzt mal in den drive mode
einfach das heißt wir schieben den
regler hoch auf 3 m und geben jetzt mal
gas an unser auspuff gerade feuer
gesprüht gesprüht jammern das hat ja bei
gott vor sorry aber ist er relativ easy
wir gehen jetzt einfach in reverse
empfahl ein bisschen zurückgehen dann
wieder in drive um dann wieder nach
vorne zu fahren und zwar von jetzt an
dem auto hier vorne vorbei das auto ist
einfach weggefahren also lieber als
fußgänger die lassen wir natürlich auch
alles schön hier weil die straße laufen
mit einer vorgefertigten schöner am
gehege fahren hier vorne meine damen und
herren muss man sich so anhalten da
kommt nämlich die polizei mal schauen
was sie veranstalten
ich hätte ihn sogar zugetraut dass ich
ihn umfahren ich weiß nicht was ich mit
diesem knüpfen hier machen kann
ach das sind blinker durchsetzen kann ok
das heißt wir fahren jetzt mal genau
vernünftig also da sind ja läuft über
die straße die polizei lässt ihn auf das
heißt ich derzeit den blinker links
junge die polizei die schon wieder fast
umgefahren blinker links ist gesetz
blinker wieder wegmachen so als parken
wir mal rückwärts ein freunde das heißt
wir bremsen jetzt hier gehen in reverse
geben ein bisschen gas
genauso parkt man einen nachlass segert
dass man doch rumlaufen kann wtf was
kann ich denn jetzt machen
hallo freunde gibt es irgendwelche leute
die mit mir unterhalten wollen hallo wie
geht's dir denn der herr hallo da alles
klar du läufst einfach durch mich durch
alles klar nach vorne der golf ist meine
karre aber es wäre halt echt geil wenn
ich in andere autos einsteigen können
das heißt ich stell mich jetzt einfach
mal neben
ich bin einfach größer als das auto ich
kann nicht in andere autos einsteigen
als sind mein eigenes also gehe ich mal
wieder hier rein wir sind in drei sätzen
den blinker links weil wir jetzt links
hier natürlich abbiegen fahren hier
links rum und jetzt würde ich sagen aber
die karimow vollspeed
wtf ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen plan
was ich jetzt hier genau beachten muss
ich mag jetzt gerade mal alles nach
regeln also ich blinken rechts von
rechts rum halte mich sogar die
geschwindigkeit begrenzt und das ich
glaube ich jetzt 30 das heißt ich war
hier gediegene 27 mal schön lang
ich weiß aber dass eine abknickende
vorfahrtsstraße ist aber ich glaube da
muss man auf jeden fall nicht blinken
das heißt jetzt so und jetzt will ich
mich mal hier rechts am rand stellen um
mal pinkeln zu gehen das heißt ich halte
jetzt hier an lasse den blinker
allerdings an damit die leute sehen okay
ich halte hier nur gerade ich will mal
sehen wie unser blinker von vorne
aussieht da
haben wir nämlich gar kein wir sitzen
wieder am auto machen den blinker jetzt
allerdings auf links natürlich schöne
schulterblick gemacht zack ist keiner
war keiner hier haben wir jetzt gerade
sogar 80er speed limit das heißt wir
fahren jetzt einfach mal rum hier ist es
jetzt nur noch ein sechziger das heißt
wir können ja auf jeden fall schon ein
bisschen gas geben
das ist kein normaler golf gti wenn der
solche komischen beck feiert die ganze
zeit hinten hat ich gebe jetzt einfach
mal vollgas ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was
ich hier genau machen muss in diesem
level gleichfalls wieder irgendwie rum
und da steht dann ja seines level falsch
gemacht solche falls man mit 100 km/h
direkt gegen die wand und warm
erst mal links blinker setzen oben steht
die ganze zeit xp aber ich weiß auch
nicht was ich da also was mir das bringt
so das ist jetzt eine ampel die setzen
roth das heißt ich setze meinen blinker
faber trotzdem weil ich keinen bock auf
verkehrsregeln habe da ist die polizei
wenn ich in die polizei fahre passiert
einfach
es passiert nix wird sagen wir kaufen
uns meine neue karre wer mir ziel den
golf gti allerdings auch die corvette
den bmw den ferrari den hammer ich bin
allerdings riesiger fan von sls amg da
wird ja nicht mehr produziert das heißt
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal hier auch
weiter die mittsommer anderem app ich
habe keinen plan wo wir jetzt hier
gerade sind der andere was ist das in c
63 amg oder irgendwie sowas er kommt
ich hab was will er denn meine karre
kostet fünf mal so viel wie deine also
säulen drive und jetzt stecken wir
einfach ganz schnell ab freunde
mal schauen wie schnell diese karte
erzählt er hat glaube ich irgendwie so
560 ps der cng und das level ist einfach
schuljahr fehlgeschlagen da vorne kommen
wieder an c63 an freunde ich weiß nicht
fertig jetzt wieder zu halten meine
karriere ein oder was will der jetzt ja
egal was was will der mann wir sitzen
allerdings wieder im sls eine
wunderschönes maße fragt mich nicht wie
führerschein bestanden habe das liegt
alles an diesem scheiß c63 ich versuche
jetzt ab zu haben bevor der hier
irgendwie ankommen kann also jetzt hier
direkt links um die kurve die karre
natürlich auch erst mal ganz schön hier
vorne huber
peter f
leider nicht rüber fahren kann da hinten
ist ein berg das finde ich echt mal
interessant wenn wir darüber fahren
würden also jetzt hier mit 100 km/h aber
auf dem berg duell
und dahin jetzt noch im bergfreunde da
fahren wir natürlich auch direkt wieder
drauf jetzt mal runter wie öl
world
unternehmen wir direkt die halfpipe
weiter und fahren natürlich rüber auf
den nächsten berg ihren 100 km/h freunde
genau so habe ich mir das vorgestellt
wir ziehen hier gerade in ganz schönen
langen drift durch das grün geht meine
damen und herren die mit 90 80 70 km h m
und jetzt drehen wir allerdings fahren
jetzt rüber auf die straße damit wir
hier nochmal ordentlich speed sammeln oh
mein gott freunde die karge der ultra ab
und jetzt aber auf den berg 140
das ich stell mir das die ganze zeit
spektakulärer falls es wirklich ist ich
ziehe mal wieder einen schönen langen
schrift über das grün fällt wir sehen
hier vorne eine stadt die gar nicht aus
wie eine pop statt es ist echt krass wie
diese karte ab geht aber ich würde sagen
da wir jetzt hier auch so ein bisschen
alles schon erkundet haben auf dieser
map wähle ich uns jetzt mal die corvette
aus und wir gehen mal auf die autobahn
wahrscheinlich ist er ist der letzte g
krasser gemacht als die corvette aber
ich hab kein bock auf die corvette
kommen wie man den audi r8 jetzt hier
vorne und gehen jetzt mal als web auf
die autobahn
das heißt wir schauen jetzt mal ob wir
hier vorne irgendwie genau losgeht sehen
hier den r8 jetzt halt einfach wirklich
überhaupt kein mensch gerade das heißt
wir können und ich war erstmal gegen die
leitplanke das heißt wir können die
recht einfach beschleunigen
ich weiß haben wir mal ganz schnell
geradeaus das ist ein sehr schönes
schild einfach weil man jetzt hier
unendlich gas geben kann wir sind schon
bei der 150 km h eigentlich müsste so
einen audi a8 noch viel krasser abgeben
des herrn v c o mein gott alter das ist
ja wie subway service im ausweichen
eigentlich müsste so ein audi a8 noch
viel krasser abgehen der ist jetzt
gerade erst bei 200 aber oh mein gott
das ist gerade ganz schön kranke mit der
steuerung audi a8 natürlich zehnzylinder
motor müsste auf jeden fall krank ab
gehen wir sind jetzt gerade bei 205 km/h
eigentlich müsste er schon easy bei 300
sein alter schwede ich war einfach die
ganze zeit gerade aus sind bei 230 ich
weiß nicht was jetzt irgendwie noch
genau hier 130 schild erhalten uns
setzen wir nicht dran aktuell die
scheiße
ja und natürlich kann die karte
autobahn hier ist doch relativ
langweilig also ich hatte mir jetzt ein
bisschen mehr von erwartet dass ihr das
vielleicht auch noch dreispurig wir
damit ein paar ausfahrten aber irgendwie
ist es nur eine rundstrecke die sich die
ganze wiederholt es gibt hier halt
normale fahrten multiplayer und karriere
ich geh jetzt mal ganz kurz auf karriere
kommen wir mal ganz kurz schauen ob dann
jedoch noch irgend was reißen kann also
hier mit dem sls amg machen wir mal
karriere auf der autobahn genau können
wir hier spielen ich weiß jetzt nicht
genau was ich immer alles klar
sicherheitsgurt okay jetzt gerade 30 km
h
so wie man das kennt
als 100 km/h dh falscher blinker
gebraucht acom unser auspuff spuckt zum
glück gar kein feuer
wir halten uns jetzt aber mal ganz schön
an die 100 km h das heißt ich geh jetzt
auf die linke spur xp - 110 ist
natürlich auch schön die sache ist
allerdings dass ich gar nicht xp dazu
gewinne also irgendwie gehen die gibt es
nur eins - und wenn ich jetzt mehr gas
geben als 100 kommt wahrscheinlich 100
oder irgendwie sofort hier ist 130
kilometer ich allerdings als raser
schneller fahren möchte setzt sich links
blinker
macht das nicht freuen etwas verboten
platz
geschlagen
ich weiß nicht
die ich meinen führerschein bestanden
habe das was jetzt ihr vom video meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat was gerne mal einen laib da wenn ihr
wollt dass nicht mehr fahrschule
simulator kacke die bereits zu beginn
gesagt ist das ganze eine kooperation
mit google play gewesen
deswegen habe ich die ganze zeit oben
auch werbe video eingeblendet gesehen
die haben einfach die möglichkeit
gegeben ein handy zu bekommen und neiße
games zu zocken und ja jetzt kommt das
outro das war's jetzt ihr vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken hier findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auch die glocken klickten dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen